مفاوضات جاريه بين فريق ترامب ومتى سمعنا
عنها اليوم لاول مره الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب ومثل ما كلنا يعني
عارفين غايب عن كبرى من الصوت السوشيال
ميديا من 20 21 وقت احداث الكابتل اللي
نحضر من بعدها من معظم من الصوت وعلى
رقصات تويتر وفيسبوك والانستغرام ويوتيوب
وغيرها ووقتها يعني هو النجوم
على تويتر كان من اصحاب الحسابات الاكثر
نشاطا وشعبيه ب 87 مليون متابع ام على
فيسبوك عنده كان 34 مليون متابع وعلى
الانستغرام 23 مليون والحسابين هذول لسه
موجودين على فكره واخر بوست عليهم من
يناير 20 واحد و20 ولكن من وقتها ما بيقدر
ينشر عليهم شيء وترامب بعد الحذر راح اطلق
منصه الخاصه
الجديد اليوم زي ما قلنا مشاهدينا فرع
المفاوضات بنت ترامب ومتى فمحامي ترامب
بعد رساله للشركات بالنيابه عنه بيطالب
فيها باعاده فوريه لحسابات الرئيس السابق
على فيسبوك وانستغرام وقالت الرساله انه
الحظر المفروض على ترامب شوه الخطاب العام
وكبتوا وقالوا لهم يلا فورا اجتماعنا ناقش
فيه عوده ترمب الفوريه
والحظر المستمر راح نعتبره جهد متعمد
لاسكات صوت
السياسي طبعا للعوده بما انه ناوي الترشح
للرئاسه للمره الثالثه وحسابات التواصل
صارت عنصر اساسي من اي حمله يعني هو طبعا
سيد العارفين في هذا الموضوع كثار على
فكره شافه الخبر واستغربوا انه يعني يرجع
فيسبوك وانستغرام مع انه لما الماسك رجع
له حسابه على تويتر ما غرد هناك ولا قال
اي شيء لكن على هذا الكلام في مصادر بتقول
انه بيدرس قال
وتكلم اكثر من مره في الموضوع وانه حتى
مستشاري عملوا له كذا مسوده لتغريدته
الاولى بعد الرجاء ماسك بالمناسبه ما فوت
خبر ترامب مع متى واللي يعني النقاش اللي
صاير بينهم معلق على تغريده مقال عن تجهيز
ترامب نفسه للرجعه للفيسبوك وتويتر وقال
انه سيكون من الممتع يعني تفرج كيف رح
تتعامل اداره مع هذا الخبر يمكن يجربه
يصلحه وكالات فيدراليه ضد تويتر هذا كلام
مصر